Uueerrgh
*bouncy noise*
Surprise! Here's an extra video for the week.
I couldn't wait until Monday, I wanted to post it over the weekend.
Katy Perry released Swish Swish,
it's been a hot topic.
I've actively tried to avoid social media so I could make this video for you
because I know how much you guys are craving this.
This is me trying to manifest that, into the world.
Let's watch Katy Perry's Swish Swish.
I've already seen a couple screen grabs to be fair,
I know Christine is in it, which makes me very excited.
Other than that, I don't know too much so.
Alright, is everyone ready?
Meaning me and all of...the couple brain cells up there?
Okay buddies, here we go.
Capitol Records, 'kay.
How did she...sh*t!
Hold on, hold on.
Hold on already.
How did she sh*t out that many basketballs and also
tell me that that doesn't look like that SNL sketch.
*SNL sketch*
It would take over, thirty thousand bowls.
To make that much oat-
Wow!
I think i get the picture!
Colon Blow must be the highest fibre cereal on the market!
Oooooohhh!
But it's-
It's funnyyy
Swish Center.
SportsCenter
Appeals to dads.
It appeals to dads.
They got the kid from Stranger Things, that's illegal.
Christine!
I can't keep up with this already.
(MV) She just seems to keep falling flat on her face. Where did they fi-
She fell.
These are jokes about basketball. Sports.
Molly Shannon- Oh my God.
They look incapable, but I think they might overcome all the odds.
That seems...awful.
Why are they going against wrestlers?
There's a lot happening here!
Am i watching YouTube Rewind?
This looks like roar.
Christine! Yes, get it girl!
Traveling! That's all travelling!
How'd you eat that basketball Christine?
I want to make a...
hypothesis that... these people never played this sport before.
Uh oh.
They appeal to every drug use
viewer.
Gronk.
Oh, we did Big Heads in Dirty 30.
Ohh! Doug the Pug made the cut!
I don't think that they're physically capable of performing athletics.
I don't watch a lot of basketball, but I don't think this is how you play it.
That seems like...
harassment.
This is YouTube Rewind.
Up?
Is that the beginning of the movie Up?
What?!
When?!
Nicki Minaj's-
What?!
This could be anyone.
We can't see her eyes, so this could be any animatronic version of Nicki Minaj.
This, Is West World Nicki Minaj.
Oh my God!
Is America Celine Dion?
Wait, is this another team that's coming to play?
Cause they look a little bit more athletic than the teams I've seen so far.
They're wearing basketball nets as skirts!
That's a DIY I've yet to see.
Get on that...um...
*stuttering*
People- you guys that do that.
Oh my God, his arm isn't broken anymore.
What was that? That seems like an illegal substance.
This is YouTube Rewind.
What, are they making out?
Wait the Chr-
Wait, is Christine ma-
What?!
Oh.
That seems very dangerous.
For her body double.
That uh...
That seems like, that someone should worry about that.
That man just died.
No one seems to care that the man with the head explosion is dead now.
The...
The referee died.
His head exploded.
Or has the coach died?
The coach died!
Coach died.
His head exploded.
His head...
Wow.
I love sports.
I can tell there's a lot of unearthed political messaging in there
that I'll have to..
watch again to find out.
This music video is the Rudi(?) of our generation.
Let me know in the comments down below, what you guys think of this music video.
And, trust me, er...
I will be reviewing Taylor Swift's Look What You Made Me Do, as soon as it comes out.
So... if that's something you care about...
Subscribe to this YouTube Channel if You haven't already.
I make videos normally Monday, Wednesday and Friday.
But I really don't...I split that...Just...
It's a surprise!
Like any- everything that happened in this music video.
Go team!
I don't know.